el país es uno de los principales
exportadores mundiales de aceite de
girasol y ucrania produce más de la
mitad del suministro mundial mientras
que rusia representa un tercio esas
exportaciones están ahora bajo amenaza
tras la guerra en ucrania teniendo
escasez consumidores en españa están
guardando reservas me dado cuenta que
hay mucha gente que lleva por la calle
incluso bombonas de 5000 litros para
enfrentar las compras por pánico los
supermercados empezaron a imponer un
límite en las compras aquí cada cliente
solo puede comprar una botella de 5
litros el 70% de las exportaciones
ucranianas pasan por el mar negro y el
tráfico allí está en un punto muerto
causando estragos en las cadenas de
suministros este experto dice que los
efectos de la guerra se mantendrán los
agricultores plantan semillas en abril y
no sabemos cómo se verá esto es ahora
suficiente mano de obras habrán
suficientes semillas para plantar
suficientes girasoles para el próximo
año con la incertidumbre sobre el futuro
del suministro los precios se inflaron y
los productores franceses de papas
fritas también sienten impacto este
contenedor tiene aceite de girasol se
vende a una fortuna mil litros cuestan
casi cuatro mil dólares hace un mes mil
litros costaban casi dos mil dólares y
nuestros precios se doblan dos países
como india podría mirar hacia estados
unidos y otras naciones para compensar
la falta de aceite pero el calendario el
conflicto dificultará las cosas para los
fabricantes estadounidenses y los
agricultores ni siquiera empezaron a
plantar sus cultivos previstos para este
año